ν μπορεί να γίνει χρισώς όλη επιονίκης υπάρχουν στάδια ξέρουν ακριβώς που πρέπει να είναι
και φυση κατάσταση τα αποτελέσματα του ξέρουν πως λεφτά χρειάζεται να επενδήσου σε πιες κατηγορές
να τον βάλουν και βήβασκαλοπάετις καλοπάτει το βγάζουν αυτό το σύστημα στην ουσία το δημουργήσαμε
εμείς μόνιμας με τον προπονιτή μου έτσισα μια μικριώματα και είναι κροάτης ο προνητησ και
ξυνεργείες με μικρές χώρες αλλά αυτόν που βλέπω και μηνα με δσαρεστεί είναι ότι α
δεν αξιοποιείται να μαθευτεί αυτό που ηδέχουμε δημρογησί ούτεαπό την κύπρια κινηστε οπλο για μο
σκοντιάν ούτε από τους κράτες τοκαι ν δε να ξιοποιθεί στα που ένα πεσετα χρονγιαδιέχο
δηλώσι ότι ιτολος άσις θα ητελευτά μολιμπιάδα ο παύλοσ ο γιός ω θα διπλώσουν τα
κατάρτια και όλες αυτές οι γνώσεις που έχουνε επετηθεί τος θα πολλα λευτά και απόι
τις διοκυβερνησίς θα χάθουν και θα πρέπει κάποιος άλλος που θα έχει το μεράκι τη
θέληση τις προπτικές τις προποθέσεις και αν μπορεί να βρι τους οικονομικούς πορους να ξεκίνηση
πλάβλυλ αυλά να το ξαναδημουργήσει απτομιδε στην ησφορά του κράτους το κράτους είναι διπλα στους
αθλητές είναι δεναι εκίνη τη βοήθεια ώε ένα παιδί σήμερα να κάνει τον ίρων του
πραγματικό ήταν τομάζτε πολύ πίσωαομικράτος είναι διπλασοαθεθέςοι δικά στους ανθητές που έχουν φέρει αποτελέσματα και
να αυτό ά εμπριον ια πολύδύσκονααλλά για να ρθει το αποτέλεσμα πρέπει να είναι δίπλασουν
να σε φέρει σε ένα βάθμο ώστε ναφήρεις και το αποτέλεσμο σίγουρα αυτό δεν το
κάνει στο βαθμού που θα μπορούσε αναγνωρίζων ότι είναι πολύδύσκον να το κάνει θα μπορούσε
μπολύ αύκολα να πουν κατά τεν αποψει μου και ολιμπιονίκες που έχουν φέρει μεγάλα ποτελέσματα
σε αθήματα βλέπε κυράκο ι ο άν άντρας καριόλουμάρχος παγτατής ελα είναι αρτήματα